[Música]
el presidente estadounidense yo byden
firmó la llamada ley de reducción de la
inflación uno de sus proyectos bandera y
que destinará entre otras cosas unos 375
mil millones de dólares para la lucha
contra el cambio climático en versión
Federal más grande en la materia
comenzó oficialmente la campaña por la
presidencia de Brasil el ex presidente
Luis Ignacio Lula da Silva quien aspira
a su tercer mandato realizó su primer
mitin político en donde criticó la
gestión de su contrincante y el
presidente Yair bolsonaro quien aspira a
la reelección y que en un evento
arremetió contra la izquierda
protestas en El Salvador ciudadanos
rechazaron la posible ampliación del
polémico estado de excepción destinado a
combatir la inseguridad pero que ha
dejado casi 50.000 detenidos y múltiples
denuncias de violaciones a los Derechos
Humanos
Hola Bienvenidos a las noticias del
continente americano en francés 24 los
saluda Andrés Meza Muñoz empezamos en
Estados Unidos el presidente Joe biden
firmó la llamada ley de reducción de la
inflación una de sus mayores banderas de
gobierno en el documento se incluye la
que es considerada como la mayor
inversión contra el cambio climático en
la historia del país unos 375 mil
millones de dólares y además aplicará
una reducción en los medicamentos
recetados según el partido demócrata la
medida que había sido aprobada por el
senado la semana pasada ayudará a
combatir el déficit Federal mientras que
los republicanos opinan que no hará
mucho para reducir los precios el
presidente estará de gira por varios
estados para explicar las ventajas de la
norma previamente hablamos con Alberto
Bernal León director de estrategia
global de XP investments sobre Cuál será
el impacto directo de esta medida
Pues a ver yo creo que hay un componente
que puede ayudar que es la expectativa
que bajen los precios de la insulina por
ejemplo la capacidad que va a tener el
Gobierno Federal de negociar con las con
los hospitales con las compañías de
seguros con las farmacéuticas etcétera
para poder disminuir los precios de la
medicina yo creo que ese es el factor
principal la verdad que esto no hace
mucho desde el punto de vista de
disminuir el costo de la gasolina o
disminuir el costo de los alimentos que
es lo que más se está afectando a los
ciudadanos de Estados Unidos en este
momento pues a ver yo creo que a mí me
gusta muchísimo todos los los planes que
hay de estímulo para para ayudar a que
crezca más que crezcan más las energías
alternativas creo que eso es una buena
noticia estos subsidios adicionales para
mejorar la electrificación O sea perdón
de volver más eficiente el sistema
eléctrico de Estados Unidos etcétera la
hay una estimación es que con esta con
la ayuda de este plan Estados Unidos
podría disminuir hasta en 50% sus
emisiones de aquí a estas 2030 Comparado
con el 2005 Y eso es una buena noticia
entonces hay que ponderar eso porque va
por el camino adecuado desde el punto de
vista del futuro del clima en el planeta
en otras noticias de Estados Unidos las
representantes republicana a la cámara
por el distrito congresional de Wyoming
sufrió una derrota en su intento por
obtener la nominación de su partido para
volver a competir por un escaño en el
congreso Jenny quien ha sido fuerte
crítica de Donald Trump y jugó un papel
destacado en la investigación contra el
ex mandatario por el asalto al Capitolio
perdió justamente ante harriet hachmann
la candidata apoyada por Trump lo que
marca una victoria para la expresidente
en su intento por derrocar a los
republicanos que apoyaron el proceso de
destitución en su contra
y comenzaron de manera oficial las
campañas presidenciales en Brasil los
dos favoritos Luis Ignacio lulada Silva
y el actual presidente Jair bolsonaro
participarán en la carrera por llegar a
la Silla del Palacio de plan alto ambos
realizaron eventos masivos en la
presencia de sus seguidores en donde
hubo críticas a contradictores políticos
al gobierno de turno y muy pocas
propuestas
una carrera presidencial que promete ser
una de las más polarizadas de la
historia de Brasil el resultado de las
elecciones del 2 de octubre se decidirá
entre el candidato de izquierdas Lula da
Silva y el Ultra derechista Yair
bolsonaro en arranque de campaña Lula
acusó al gobierno de bolsonaro de
mentira su base electoral
quiero decirle presidente genocida que
no queremos Un gobierno que distribuya
armas queremos Un gobierno que
distribuya libros no queremos Un
gobierno que alimente el odio queremos
Un gobierno que alimente el amor estas
últimas semanas para suavizar su imagen
ante los votantes que les son
históricamente hostiles Lula aumentó sus
reuniones con líderes empresariales y
eligió Alex gobernador conservador del
estado de Sao Paulo Gerardo alkmin como
compañero de Fórmula
por otro lado la campaña de Jair
bolsonaro vive una dinámica inesperada
desde hace unos días A mediados de Julio
el presidente liberó casi 8.000 millones
de dólares de gasto público para las
clases más vulnerables y sigue centrando
su discurso en la fe y la moral
cristiana con el objetivo de recuperar
al electorado evangélico que le votó
masivamente en 2018 y representa más de
un tercio de la población
nuestro país no quiere dar pasos atrás
no queremos ideología de género en las
escuelas nuestro país no quiere
legalizar las drogas nuestro país
respeta la vida desde su Concepción
nuestro país no quiere convertirse en un
Aliado del comunismo en otros países sin
embargo según las encuestas Luna sigue
siendo el favorito y para Yair bolsonaro
el desafío es todavía considerable el
presidente lo apuesta todo al 7 de
septiembre día del Bicentenario de la
Independencia y fecha en la que tiene
previsto organizar grandes
concentraciones en todo el país en El
Salvador un grupo de personas se
manifestaron en rechazo a la posible
ampliación del estado de excepción que
rige en ese país centroamericano desde
el pasado mes de marzo organizaciones de
Derechos Humanos anunciado
irregularidades en la aplicación de esta
medida con miles de denuncias Rafael
Pérez nos cuenta más
un reclamo de libertad frente a la
asamblea legislativa madres y familiares
de Quienes fueron detenidos durante el
régimen de excepción se pronunciaron en
contra de la eventual ampliación de la
medida los nombres de los detenidos
presidían la protesta exijo al gobierno
que libere a esta gente hombres y
mujeres que están detenidos
inocentemente para el corazón en la mano
mi hijo nunca
anduvo delinquiendo yo le pido a Dios y
a este gobierno le dé libertad a los
jóvenes hombres y mujeres inocentes las
autoridades se resguardaron el área de
junta de la asamblea ante la llegada de
los manifestantes Y es que el gabinete
de seguridad pedirá la próxima semana al
congreso que apruebe una nueva
ampliación del régimen de excepción los
reclamos llegaron de disímiles maneras
porque la atención cuando bemmen ya me
lo pongo bien mal incluso exigiendo el
derecho a ser atendidos a golpe de
megáfono por parte de aquellos
funcionarios que tienen la
responsabilidad en torno a este tema el
estado de excepción en El Salvador se
encuentra vigente desde finales de marzo
en él se suspenden las garantías
constitucionales para darle poderes
especiales al ejecutivo organizaciones
humanitarias de diversas partes del
mundo han recopilado al menos 3.000
denuncias por violaciones a los Derechos
Humanos casi 50.000 personas han sido
detenidas desde el inicio de la
disposición uno pocos datos que se
conocen oficialmente
en Venezuela el colectivo de maestros
lleva varias semanas saliendo a las
calles de diferentes ciudades del país
para exigir a Nicolás Maduro el pago de
un Bono vacacional íntegro los maestros
son uno de los que más han sufrido la
crisis económica que golpea al país
desde hace varios años al punto que más
de la mitad de los docentes del sistema
de Educación han abandonado Venezuela
erly Ruiz es un profesor de sociología
venezolano pero a pesar de tener una
formación Superior y de ser un
trabajador público su salario no le
sirve para vivir algo que le ha obligado
a ser también repartidor y dependiente
en una tienda de vinos pluriempleos con
los que en total apenas alcanza 400
dólares mensuales una situación que
denunciar
1400 dólares o sea será lo que era el
monto de un profesor profesor le digo en
una era antes prerevolucionario un
profesor con 1400 dólares no tenía que
tener esos trabajos jornaleros se podía
dedicar plenamente la investigación
actualmente mi sueldo son 90 dólares
Entonces sí ciertamente yo no tengo
digamos la alternativa pero el caso de
early Ruiz no es algo aislado los
maestros han sido uno de los colectivos
más afectados por la crisis que sacude
al país desde hace años una situación
que ha hecho que miles de ellos salgan a
las calles durante estas semanas para
denunciar sus malas condiciones y
reclamar el pago
del Bono vacacional un extra que oscila
entre los 100 y 200 dólares que el
gobierno de Nicolás maduro todavía no ha
pagado
ahorita dónde está somos nosotros el
pueblo que los tienen aquí donde está
ahorita entonces que que se aboque y que
cumpla con lo que tiene que cumplir como
presidente tras las protestas El
Ejecutivo prometió que esta semana se
pagará íntegramente la cantidad Aunque
hasta el momento eso no ha sucedido la
pobreza ha hecho que desde 2017 más del
50% de los 370.000 profesores que tenía
Venezuela salieran del país
el gobierno de México recibió
oficialmente la solicitud de Estados
Unidos para extraditar al
narcotraficante Rafael Caro Quintero
acusado por Washington de delincuencia
organizada y la muerte de un agente de
la DEA el anuncio sobre la solicitud lo
hizo el presidente Andrés Manuel López
Obrador la extradición de Caro Quintero
fundador del Cartel de Guadalajara ha
conseguido tener amparos para suspender
de forma indefinida su envío a Estados
Unidos por lo que el procedimiento
podría demorar varias semanas
hasta que ese informativo enfras 24
Gracias por acompañarnos
[Música]